trong tương tiên được các cơ quan hỏi ra, nhiều nước đã phát cạnh máo hình cấp từ cơm dân hiện đang ở ýván,
giảm ối cảnh có cuộc biểu tình tiếp tục lâu thân.
Đại xúc quan nghĩ kêu hỏi người dân dưới ýván ngày tất,
cạnh nhau dưới chuyển sang, aminia hoặc thủy kỳ, điều ăn nền cho phép.
Trong trường hợp không thể dưới đi, thì người dân cần chuyển bị các nhiều yếu phẩm cần thiến như lương thực thuốc man.
Công ngày, bộ hỏi rao cân ra, thủy điện và đại hoàn,
cũng đưa ra quyền cám nghiêm ngạc, nhấn mạnh mối độ dùi sau cao và hạnh chế cứ chuyển đi tới Yván.
Anh đò, o sư lia và ýn uống đi si nhà cũng quyền cao công dân theo sợ sát tình hình và sẵn sẵn sợ tàn nếu cần thiết.
Bình nhiều hẳng hàn không tạm nừng bay tới Yván kìa bây giờ đi bằng nông bộ trở thành lợi trọng khai thiệt.
Các cua ra nhấn mạnh ước tiên bảo đam an toàn cho công dân,
đồng thời trình bị các phương an ước phó hình cấp.
Chúng tôi đã nói, hãy chừng Yván Sẽ et bắt,
Argyt Tiet Bố, tình hình trong nếu hiện hoàn toàn năm 2020,
hàng đệnh biểu tình xuất phát từ khó khăn kinh tế và bị kinh động bởi giữ khăn thiệt tư bên ngoài.